already the icon is cockroach it all
right get away this week's random video
game as supplied by GameSpot users
psycho tomb a darkness is solid I have
never heard of this game in my life
it's called bad mojo that looks like
anything crazy happened when I looked at
that haha that strange Lobby that was
supposed to be my mother's a weird
feeling like a twisting spell
mojo
what
get up there oh hey cockroach friends
what's up hey what's going on it's just
some sort of insect for tea
my tentacles my tentacles appear to be
underneath some sort of stove
I should probably walk into the flame
well okay
I have a certain amount of lives maybe I
should do that oh god you're all dead
this is deeply awful oh it's like a
sticky pad oh Jesus Christ
this gave us the worst yeah rots blood
is too thick rats blood is thicker than
water
and it's up what's wrong with your face
oh Jesus Christ
and then nibble on your town got a
teabag your town horse cigarette always
a spider that's terrif right I'm out of
here
that spider trying to have a cigarette
that was going on Nick have a smoke you
got any smokes you got any smokes -
coffee pot for this well your life
since your last one I just want to spoil
drugs give me Dracula badges
yeah
so that's what happens in cockroaches
died okay spider wants to have a smoke
but I'm gonna go [ __ ] up his bread first
I feel like I'm supposed to set his web
on fire with the thing there pull bulky
here have a smoke you'll feel better
about everything have a smoke is it like
impossible to win this man because he's
here and I go up here hey come over here
let's do this real quick no [ __ ] that up
when I made it way harder to do it this
time
often [ __ ] sake what the [ __ ] was that
smoke on that yeah that's right
sucks bladder
okay hey what's going on for the party
you got going on here you're dead anyway
just let me 69 in I thought I'm supposed
to get something the prophecy set gets
up this I don't think the rent is
particularly high mr. Scott who wants it
here rat babies what the [ __ ] was that
Oh Amy
I'll get some [ __ ] dead
I waste a lot of paint are you son of
them commit suicide
see I know what's gonna happen if things
are closed up again as they se like
[ __ ]
let's get across
now get out of the [ __ ]
I'm sure the people who made this game
was still getting money first 18 years
they ology you know what sure yeah sure
evil bastard cash right okay
that's been random encounter this week
thank you very much for for hanging out
during that off you could have been
playing watchdogs but you decided to
stick around here and I appreciate it
happy Rhonda me kanaday see you guys
next week if you have any suggestions
tweet at Tigers why bless your second
suit may in which keep the teaser
no thanks for the recommendation I
appreciate it that was interesting I'll
see you guys next week